hi there Steve here it's day 17 of my
Korean 90-day challenge
remember by the way that I'm not
starting my Korean from scratch alright
this is my third major push at Korean
today I want to talk about the power of
listening and reading and it can be very
short basically since I last spoke with
Hannah in Korean we have a Skype chat
and you saw that here as one of my
videos I have not spoken any Korean I
have tho done a lot of listening and
reading and I have the sense that I'm
starting to get a handle on Korean how
it flows my brain cells are getting used
to Korean they've been exposed to all of
his Korea so today in the office I
decided to have a chat with Hannah
totally unprepared and we spoke for like
six or seven minutes we've recorded it
rather than put it up today without any
translation we're gonna wait a couple of
days I don't know whether we'll just
have a transcript in English or whether
we'll have subtitles depends what they
can do in the office but I spoke much
better I felt much more comfortable
speaking Korean and Hannah was quite
surprised at my improvement in basically
a week and I know that if I spend
another two weeks or even a month with
it's the degree of intensive listening
and reading that I'm doing now I will
just speak better and better eventually
to speak really well I have to speak a
lot but in the meantime without speaking
at all I am greatly building up my
ability to communicate to speak in the
language and I think that the time that
I'm spending daily two hours even more
listening and reading even though a lot
of it is just listening in the car going
to the hockey game coming back and so
forth is a more valuable use of my time
than trying to struggle to speak if I
had simply continued say a week ago when
I had that conversation with Hannah and
if I had spent most of my time then the
next day speaking with her and the next
day and only slightly improving my
ability to express myself that that
would not be as effective a use of my
time as this massive listening and
reading becoming familiar
the language building in my vocabulary
so the power of listening and reading
and on Wednesday you should be able to
see that discussion here at YouTube bye
for now